you're on the trail going downhill and
yours Wow look at that tree well look at
that bird Wow look at that animal every
time you come it's different you never
get bored about nature my name is Jose
Pablo young man of India and I'm an
outdoor adventure guide Elser is a
natural reserve in a south part of
Okinawa it's a beautiful volcano that
opens to the Pacific coast
overall the park is 2,500 acres and
there is a little more than 25 miles of
trails the group that started L sewer
wanted to conserve the land but they
needed a way to make it sustainable and
that's when the idea of having
recreation activities came into the plan
my favorite activity to do here is
mountain biking
it's a pristine rainforest with huge
old-growth trees the animals in the park
are protected and that's what makes them
feel free and comfortable being around
people you can see the culture
difference between a protected area and
one that is not outside the property the
land is being used for agriculture so
what that means is that there's gonna be
a lot of deforestation having places in
the country where you can go and I truly
enjoy and preserve nature it's beautiful
I feel grateful that these places
actually exist
you
[Music]